c'est un rendez vous attendu chaque
année depuis 1977 les journées
gastronomiques de sologne à romorantin
39e édition aujourd'hui et demain un
rendez vous culinaire qui réunit de
nombreux exposants on va retrouver sur
place un art georges et menait alain
georges
la grande nouveauté cette année c'est un
déménagement de l'événement vous n'êtes
pas aux halles mais dans l'ancien site
de l'usiné matra
c'est exactement ça c'est le bâtiment
que tout le monde appelle ici fabrique
normand 4200 mètres carrés alors bien
sûr qui permet d'accueillir un plus
grand nombre d'exposants le nombre pose
de 70 504 et d'accueillir également un
grand nombre de concours
voyez derrière moi ils ont entre 13 et
18 ans et ces jeunes gens sont en train
de confectionner du sucré du salé à base
de pommes exclusivement il y aura bien
sûr des prix notamment une journée avec
un grand chef donc de très nombreuses
activités des ateliers des dégustations
ainsi juste derrière la caméra il y à un
cours de pâtisserie qui est pronostiqué
exactement sucre artistique autant dire
que ce sont des oeuvres d'art qui sont
juste devant moi y compris bien sûr
meilleur qui est derrière la caméra et
avec qui ce soir nous vous proposons de
découvrir le lièvre à la royale c'est un
championnat du monde